so donald trump is the perennial victim
according to him
right he is now retweeting the
conspiracy theory from former love
connection host chuck woolery
that his own cdc is lying about
coronavirus
in order to hurt trump's chances at
re-election now i don't know about you
i'm sick and tired of trump constantly
being the victim guy who's been wealthy
his whole life
was handed a business thanks to his
dad's money is president of the u.s
from his rhetoric you would believe that
he was the biggest victim there is
except he's the most privileged person
there is and now there's a conspiracy
theory which was put on twitter
to start with by former game show host
chuck woolery
trump retweeted it and the way it goes
is quote the most outrageous lies are
the ones about covid19
everyone is lying the cdc media
democrats doctors not all but most that
we are told to trust
i think it's all about the election and
keeping the economy from coming back
which is about the election i'm sick of
it then trump retweeting about this
issue of opening schools also what chuck
woolery
said quote there is so much evidence yes
scientific evidence that schools should
open this fall
it's worldwide and it's overwhelming but
no
we have a medical situation a global
hundred year pandemic
and you have a reality tv show host
president amplifying the messages
of the former host of the tv show love
connection and what they are amplifying
are messages that run directly counter
to what medical experts are saying
the u.s keeps breaking its own record
for new cases in a single day
the death toll is around a hundred and
forty thousand remember trump said once
it would be sixty thousand maybe seventy
thousand
do you get why the world is laughing at
us but also increasingly crying instead
of laughing
we've handled the virus as close to as
badly as any country out there
and in the midst of 60 to 70
000 new cases a day a reality tv host
president retweets a game show host
republican
as if they know more than the medical
community i told you earlier
the white house has released what is
essentially opposition research
on dr anthony fauci and trump is instead
of standing with the doctors
standing with chuck woolery we are a
global laughing stock
and this is why i said earlier we can't
allow them to turn the next three and a
half months into statues and flags
this is the red alert failure now you
know in terms of the list of things
fauci got wrong
and why trump is increasingly retweeting
chuck woolery and not fouchy
about she got masks wrong that's right
fauci got
asymptomatic spread wrong fauci has
corrected himself
but trump said in february our 15 cases
will soon be zero
he hasn't apologized he's not admitted
fault trump said in february case
numbers are going to go down not up he
was wrong
trump said in march were we have the
virus under control we didn't
trump said in april what about injecting
bleach and isopropyl alcohol you get the
picture so this is very very dangerous
talk
the maskless followers are making it
worse
just look at what's happening in florida
look at what's happening
in arizona arguably the two worst places
in the world
to be right now i don't know what we
need to change people's minds
like do we need video of icus so people
see what it is that happens and what's
going on
will they understand graphic video some
of these folks i don't know
but what we know is we've got to remove
him we have three and a half months to
go and at this point
chuck woolery chuck woolery will have
more about this
on the show's instagram page
davidpakmanshow
on instagram privacy.com is one of our
sponsors and they're giving you five
dollars
just for using their free service at
privacy.com
pacman privacy is a service i've been
using for a while now
i love it it saves me a bunch of
headaches it's completely free
and it's very quick to set up and here's
how it works when you pay for something
online or over the phone
instead of exposing your real credit
card number
privacy lets you generate virtual card
numbers
the payments are withdrawn from your
checking account but your real card
number
stays completely private and you do it
all with one click you can autofill the
card number in your web browser
on the phone you can create 12 virtual
cards a month you can set spending
limits
freeze them delete them whenever you
want i especially love it for free
trials where you need to give a credit
card number
because i can destroy the virtual card
number as soon as i give it to the
company and i know i won't be charged in
the future
if you're ordering food over the phone
why do i need to give a restaurant my
real card number
i don't have to companies don't have to
know who you are
your real credit card number is
protected from the data breaches that
happen unfortunately more often than we
would like and it's completely free
they do have a paid version with
different tiers where you can create
more virtual credit card numbers per
month cash back rewards extra security
features
but go ahead and sign up for the free
service it's a no-brainer companies
can't charge you unexpectedly
you're protected from identity theft it
costs you nothing
and privacy is giving you five dollars
to spend
just for signing up when you go to
privacy.com
pacman